wearing weighted clothing has obvious
appeal for anyone who's a fan of
Dragonball this is a common trope and
Dragonball Goku or whoever else piccolo
will be fighting an opponent they won't
be getting very far cuz they're not fast
enough or strong enough and then they'll
reveal that they're wearing weighted
clothing all along they'll take it off
it will thump onto the floor and shake
the ground and then they'll be super
fast super strong and they'll wipe the
floor with whoever they're fighting see
Goku vs TN or piccolo versus the
androids and in fact training under
increased gravity conditions is a common
trope across Dragonball because of
course we also have the scene where Goku
trains with King Kai using two-ton
wristbands or whatever they are and then
you have the gravity room where they
train under times 10 times a hundred
gravity and very quickly develop insane
strength and agility and the cool thing
is that this is pretty similar to how it
works in real life you take a weighted
vest that makes you heavier and then you
perform lots of repetitions of the
exercise that you'd normally do and it's
got a really cool name as well some
people call it hyper gravity training
which is just awesome it can also be
called gravity doping and it really does
work that way it allows you to make a
normal movement more difficult so that
when you perform it without the weight
you become super fast super powerful etc
to take a chin-up for example you're
doing pull-ups and you want to get
stronger you want to be able to do a
muscle up or a clapping pull-up there's
a few ways you could go about this maybe
you change the movement slightly to do
one-armed chin-ups for instance one arms
pull-ups that's not a perfect analog for
the movement you're trying to train
otherwise you can increase the rep range
just do more repetitions of those
pull-ups but again this is training
muscle endurance not explosiveness you
can perform the exercise more
explosively but it's not as efficient as
just adding extra weight and now you
need to recruit more muscle fiber in
order to be more explosive more fast
twitch muscle fiber in order to generate
more power through that movement through
the exact same movement then when you go
back to that movement and train without
the weighted vest you'll find that you
can much more easily launch yourself up
to the Year you almost can't help
yourself from flying up straight past
the bar krisily pull-ups are one example
but there's loads of other exercises
that are well suited to this pretty much
any calisthenics so things like crawls
things like push-ups
press ups clapping press ups things like
squats air squats pistol squats which
are also extra difficult because you now
got your weight
mind you all kinds of things can be made
more difficult by wearing a weighted
vest
studies show that performing jumps with
a weighted vest will increase your jump
height which is no surprise because once
again you're recruiting more muscle
fiber more faster to muscle fiber
through the exact same technique these
studies are very limited though one
often quoted study looking at the effect
of weighted vests on jump height family
effect was actually extremely minor and
that there was no noticeable change in
women weirdly well the most notable
change was observed was in the initial
pre-take-off velocity how quickly the
participants were able to drive their
bodies through the ground to launch
upwards that makes a lot of sense given
that the vest would help them to recruit
more muscle fiber more quickly as they
made this movement it's just that this
small difference didn't translate to
massive gains in jump height the study
has a lot of methodological problems
though for instance I only had 18
participants who are all recruited from
a college and they were not given nearly
enough time to train in order to see
long-term results the study only looked
at immediate changes chances are that
over time and practice and training
improvements in the acceleration and
movement would translate to much greater
gains in jump height this study used a
vest weighing 15% of body weight which
we'll see is kind of the recommendation
of course at the same time weighted
clothing is fantastic if you want to add
a drop set to your calisthenics routine
so drop set means doing as much as you
can of a really heavy weight then
lowering the weight so that you can keep
going and go past failure this is great
for metabolic stress and it really
triggers rapid muscle growth is also
great for muscle endurance this is
normally hard to do with calisthenics or
bodyweight exercises once again unless
you change the biomechanics of that
movement essentially doing a different
moon or if you take the weighted vest
off before you reach failure you'll
benefit from what's called the post
activation potentiation but this means
is because you've recruited more fast
twitch muscle fiber you've used more
networks in your brain related to that
they're now lit up they're kind of
primed to their warm their resting
potential is increased meaning they're
easier to recruit next time that means
that you can't help but recruit more
force when going through that movement
pattern and that's why when you perform
a really heavy movement then go on to a
lighter movement that lighter movement
feels really light in this case if you
perform say three chin-ups using a
weighted vest took off that weighted
vest weighted for 30 seconds and then
perform more chin-ups you'd find you
were flying into feels too
light just like googly at the same time
training with the weighted vest is also
a great form of cardio you'll find that
when you train this way you burn more
calories simply as a result of wearing
that vest you don't have to do anything
different in one study it was shown that
walking with a weighted vest equivalent
to 15 percent of the wearer's body
weight could help me to burn 12 or 15
percent more calories without doing
anything differently and this makes a
lot of sense because you need to creep
more muscle to perform the same task and
muscle requires oxygen meaning the heart
needs to work faster to deliver the
oxygen and the nutrients there from my
personal experience training something
like a rope climb with a weighted vest
which is brutal by the way but make sure
to really build up to it it's also very
hard on the body is a fantastic way to
get your heart rate going to be really
panting and breathing heavily just an
excellent form of resistance cardio and
it's better in my experience than just
increasing the weight on a resistance
machine for the heart at least likewise
I think that it's going to burn more
calories than walking whilst just
holding dumbbells and the reason for
this I think is because the way is
evenly distributed across the body
you need to deliver extra oxygen and
extra nutrients to all those muscles
meaning the heart needs to work extra
hard instead of just to one point at the
same time there's no benefit of momentum
you can't cheat is everywhere all the
time and so you end up gasping for air
and burning more calories where this
throughout a normal workout potentially
burn an extra 12 to 15% more calories
and as a fantastic way to very quickly
transform your body compositions one
study looking at participants going
through military-style training for six
weeks found that wearing a weighted vest
could improve their maximal oxygen
consumption by a hundred percent
compared with a non vest wearing control
group though this wasn't actually
statistically significant with once
again only 37 participants in total at
the same time this turns every exercise
into a weight-bearing exercise every
activity into a weight-bearing activity
and this can also help to strengthen and
harden your bones to prevent injury and
just make you tougher they should be go
ahead and act like Goku or piccolo and
wear weighted clothing all the time
unfortunately not there are a couple of
limitations the first one is they're
having a lot of weight on your shoulders
in particular can put a lot of strain on
your body like quite doing things like
explosive jumping is going to look put a
lot of impact on your knees and that
could be bad for you of course you need
to be careful you need to limit the
amount you're doing you certainly need
to build up to it I'd recommend not
using too much weight to begin with that
fifth
percent is a really good option actually
and you'll find that you don't need much
more than that when you're first
starting out I certainly don't you
always have the option of making the
move slightly more difficult rather than
adding more weight there are some ways
you can mitigate this for instance some
weighted vests try to take some of the
weight off your shoulders and put it
across your waist but it's still an
awful lot of strain on the body so I
wouldn't recommend doing this all day
every day plus you get really hot
it chafes you just beat yourself up
basically the other problem with this is
that wearing weighted vest all day would
change your center of gravity and that
would potentially alter the way that
your brain thinks about your body or get
too used to moving with the weights so
that it would become less efficient at
moving without the weight so you might
struggle with things like balance your
body has learned to balance with your
weight over countless years of practice
if you suddenly put more weight on top
than down below you're gonna mess that
up a little bit if the weight was
perfectly distributed across your body
that might be a different story but no
piece of equipment can accomplish quite
that unless I go into a gravity route
that said it is a really cool concept if
you'd like to see me attempt to go a
whole day or a couple of days wearing a
weighted vest let me know in the
comments and we can see if we can make
that happen so I hope fans video useful
interesting let me know if you use a
weighted vest let me know what other
cool training tools or methods you use
in the comments down below subscribe to
the channel if you want more like this
and thanks a ton for watching this I'll
see you next time bye for now